CBS News confirms the El Paso shooting
suspects mother called police weeks
before the massacre because she was
concerned about her son owning an a
k-style assault rifle
police say Patrick Cruces used a weapon
like that to kill 22 people at an El
Paso Walmart on Saturday the 21 year old
alleged white supremacist is charged
with capital murder Janet shamlian is in
El Paso Janet what do we know about the
mother's phone call well Dana good
morning this raises new questions about
whether there may have been red flags
about the suspect before the mass
shooting but in a statement the family's
attorney says that the mother's call to
the Allen Police Department was purely
informational the family's attorney
Chris Ayres told us Lorri Cruz had quote
absolutely no fear of violence nor any
belief of an intent to do harm instead
she was concerned about her 21 year old
son owning an assault-style rifle due to
his age and lack of experience with that
type of firearm she did not identify
herself or her son to police the
attorney tells us the Ellen Police
Department did not file the call or
follow up on it and a public safety
officer told Lori her son was legally
old enough to purchase the weapon now we
don't know whether the gun she called
about was the same ak-47 style firearm
used in the attack his family says the
Allen Police Department did nothing but
a good job answering Lori's questions
about gun ownership in a statement on
Sunday the Allen Police Department said
in its database it has only three minor
incidents involving the gunman it also
said that it had not received any
inquiries about the gunman or any type
of incident that he may be related to
related in rather we did reach out to
the Allen Police Department about the
moms call but have not heard back
Anthony all right Janet thank you